Michael I've learned you since you were  a child  neva gift  you always have if there's an answer to  your disease you'll find it  [Music]  I should have died years ago  why am I still here if not to fix this I  have a rare blood disease and I'm  running out of time video  this could be my last chance  [Music]  you're up to something what is it  that's not exactly label  I want to see you get hurt more than you  already have this would be a cure  at what cost  [Music]  I went from time  [Music]  of increased strength is speed  the ability to use echolocation  and then overpowering urge to consume  blood  [Music]  how far are we allowed to go  we'll fix something that's broken  until the remedy  is worse than the disease  Michael Morbius got tired of doing a  little good guy thing up what's up guy  [Music]